all right this is a really important
debunk
ivermectin has become all the rage as a
possible treatment for covid among some
americans
except there aren't actually any blind
randomized controlled trials in humans
with a placebo group that prove
ivermectin is good for covet and humans
recently iver mekhton got a big
publicity boost
because joe rogan took it along with
multiple other medications when he got
covered about a week and a half ago
and then in a recent segment on his show
with comedian tom segura
rogan cited something that tons of
people are citing he said listen japan
said let's use it japan is super
conservative on medications on elements
of medical and yet japan said use
ivermectin for covid except they
actually didn't
this is a huge red flag debunk that we
have to do so let's start with what joe
rogan said on his program and then go
from there it's uh
it's supposed to have uh what is the
exact
thing it's supposed to do
there's there's something that i
highlighted
um
and this is obviously i'm not a doctor
it says ivory mechtin was found to be a
blocker
of viral
uh replica replicase
r-e-p-l-i-c-a-s-a proteas and i don't
know what this word is
human t-m-p-r-s-s-2
i don't know but what they didn't
highlight is that i got better yeah you
got better questions try to make it seem
as if like
i'm doing some wacky sh that's
completely ineffective right cnn was
saying that i'm a distributor of
misinformation also that was the other
thing that happened
the um
in tokyo in japan which is apparently
uh they're very conservative about the
medication that they they use
and the medications that they
endorse but the tokyo medical
association chairman held a live press
conference recommending ivermectin to
all doctors for all kovid patients okay
so there's a lot there a lot of it we
already looked at last week uh let's
focus on the japan thing
the the claim is there was this
conference press conference in japan and
at the press conference they said
doctors should use ivermectin and this
is being endlessly repeated it's being
endlessly posted the same article keeps
getting posted
and
the truth is that that video
is from february it's being posted now
as if this is a new development based on
studies of ivermectin it's not okay the
video has been floating around of a
chairperson in the japanese medical
association saying we recommend doctors
in japan use ivermectin to treat covid19
it's being posted now late august early
september as if it was just filmed and
is based on recent data it was filmed in
february it's not new the video is from
before there was really any
investigation of ivermectin for covet
19. it is now seven months later
japan has not approved of ivermectin to
be used to treat covid19 and in fact
after the february statement that people
have been posting japan's health
ministries covid19 treatment guidelines
were revised in july
and they put ivermectin on a list of
drugs whose efficacy and safety
have not been established that's july
so the guidelines refer to reports that
the drug does not improve mortality for
covet it does not shorten
hospitalization for covid it does not
accelerate reducing viral loads in
patients with mild symptoms so first of
all the fda
the who and other organizations they
have opinions about ivermectin which you
could look at so already saying we're
going to ignore all of these opinions
and just look at what japan said
that's already strange like if you're
going to choose to ignore all of it and
say i'm only going to look at what japan
is doing you're already cherry-picking
but
even if you say i'm going to only look
at japan the most recent statement from
japan is this doesn't work ivermectin
doesn't work so it
do when people post that
do not be swayed by it now one other
thing
in the segment
rogan says
i took ivermectin and i got better
this is the epitome of specious reason
reasoning i would love to be back on
joe's program and to talk about this
you have a condition which most people
recover from right like remember the
death rate overall of covid
it depends on how many people never get
tested but we believe that that the
death rate is somewhere between 0.8
and 1.5
roughly um in terms of the infection
fatality rate it includes the fact that
some people never get tested most people
recover from covid
regardless of what medications they take
when you take ivermectin
and azithromycin
and monoclonal antibodies
and prednisone steroids and vitamin
drips there is no possible way you can
attribute one recovery to one of the
things that you took especially when
most people recover without taking
anything it's just not an empirical
statement it's an anecdotal statement
now believe me i get emails from people
saying david why are you against
ivermect why aren't you open to
ivermectin the second we have a blind
placebo-controlled randomized controlled
trial of ivermectin that says it works i
will be right there supporting it i said
the same thing about hydroxychloroquine
and lots of other things we had the
combination of two hiv drugs that were
being looked at all these things a
couple of these
became politicized and popular
mostly among the right
i don't have i'm completely agnostic
about all of these things give me the
double-blind placebo-controlled trials
that say they work for kovid and i will
be right there saying let's go ahead and
do this we do not have that evidence
right now for ivermectin people pointing
to japan are focusing on something said
in february when japan updated their
recommendations in july
it has to stop
it has to stop let me know your thoughts
you can find me on twitter at deepakman
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance i love using free trials
because i know i won't be charged when
the trial is over if i use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free and like i
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy.com
slash pacman